les allemands eux aussi viennent de
faire les frais d'économie draconiennes
décidées par le gouvernement et là bas
ce sont surtout les médecins se sont
rebellés ils ne veulent pas voir leurs
revenus
entamée et jugent leur exercice de la
médecine menacé par sa liberté
les caisses d'assurance maladie sont
submergés sous les frais médicaux et
pharmaceutiques
en ce moment les allemands dépensent 27
fois plus pour leur santé qu'en 1950
cette facture santé est à présent
impayable par l'économie allemand le
gouvernement s'est donc décidé d'agir
pour freiner la valence
premiers visés les médecins
l'assainissement de l'assurance maladie
demande le médecin ne peut pas vraiment
se servir
on demande par exemple si les prix des
médicaments
l'élite régionale
d'après les statistiques donc re testé
d'ailleurs en moyenne 1 médecins
pratiquant l'année dernière
190 nîmes à l'arraché ce serait après
douze années le corps médical se
reconnaît en effet une situation
matérielle privilégié dans la société
allemande de façon conditionnelle
on se montre donc prêt à certains actifs
nous sommes tous d'accord il fait qu'il
faut faire des économies
à mon avis on devait commencer ces
restrictions
ces économies au niveau de la
consommation des médicaments mais pour
faire cela il a vanté un besoin
d'institutions et d'ailleurs contrôle de
la consommation des médicaments
la phrase est prononcée elle sera plus
de plein fouet une industrie
pharmaceutique qui devra apprendre sur
20000 médicalement pour ce sens maladies
répertoriées traiteront surtout dans un
pays où des cantiques et une nuits de
somnifères et autres tranquillisants
sont vendus chaque année
il reste encore deux ans au médecin pour
trouver de concert avec les caisses
d'assurance maladie le chemin d'une
croissance raisonnable et supportable
d'être absente et si cette autogestion
libéral de la médecine de mecs encore
débouché sur une faille
il ne fait pas de doute que l'état de
bonnes appliquerait des mesures divise
les médecins seraient en liberté
surveillée
les fonctionnaires auraient lannoy